Peggy 18
life is about moments moments that stay
with you and resonate each time you
close your eyes creating these moments
is what we strive to do as game
developers in this respect The Witcher 3
Wild Hunt will be exceptional so it
deserves something extraordinary
something meaningful to complement it
we've made something that captures a
moment in time and encapsulated it's
like an instant from an epic story right
there on your desk we wanted it to seem
monumental classical as if it issued
from legends of old about a hero
battling a ferocious mythical beast the
process of creating a figure like this
is long and complex there are three
stages each of which contributes
something essential to the collectible
in its final form
we created literally hundreds of
sketches before arriving at the final
concept we envisioned Geralt battling a
myriad of different fantastic creatures
we studied the mythos of one-on-one
struggles the anatomy of combat all to
find the one perfect idea the Gryphon
really resonated with us it's a proud
creature a creature that like Geralt
commands respect the figure blends a
classical portrayal of a hero with a
dynamic rich composition reminiscent of
baroque sculpture we wanted to capture
the essence of instinct show the
combatants reacting when there's no time
to think you can see the raw force of
gerelds blow and the primal reflexes of
the Gryphon as it tries to break loose
during this phase we focused on
achieving a perfect melding of Geralt
and the Gryphon in sculpture we wanted
to freeze them in combat illustrate that
won't in minut detail this is where
sculpture can ideally marry the dynamic
and the static it is this that
distinguishes it as an art form from 3d
printing or mass production of
low-quality figures
Orion artist knows what details to
emphasize to bring out subtleties like
the feeling of real skin or the softness
of feathers
reproducing an artwork is a difficult
task
we had one aim everything I needed to be
identical to the one created in the
workshop we used poly stone the best
material available for this purpose
given its weight and slightly rough
stone like texture polished all these
months have passed for replicating the
feel of an original sculpture this
attention to detail carries over to the
colouring process as each figure is
meticulously painted by hand weighing
roughly four and a half pounds this
10-inch figure of Geralt battling a
Griffin is something you'll love to have
on your desk